sans
eux Paris ne serait pas vraiment Paris
ils offrent les points de vue les plus
magiques sur les grands monuments de la
capitale les ponts de Paris ils engjemb
la scène sur 13 km de long ils sont les
lieux de balade préférés des touristes
et des Parisiens à l'image du célèbre
Pont Neuf on a ce pont qui est très beau
qui est majestueux tout ça est
absolument magnifique et franchement
l'endroit est magique certains datent du
Moyen-Âge d'autres ont tout juste 20
ans ils ont posé les grands axes qui
structurent encore aujourd'hui la ville
lumière l'urbanisme de Paris est centré
sur la scène par conséquence se pose la
question de la circulation entre les
deux rives ils ont d'abord été fait de
bois puis de
Pierre le pont est lieu un peu
stratégique il a un péage il y a une
douane en quelque sorte fa payer pour
faire traverser les marchandises
aujourd'hui ils sont en métal en béton
ou en matériaux ultra
performant ils sont le témoignage vivant
des meilleures connaissances technique
de chaque époque faut jamais oublier que
ce sont des ouvrages exceptionnels
compliqués
uniqu de quelle façon les bâtisseurs
ont-ils érigé ces ponds audacieux
capable de résist à des masses toujours
plus
[Musique]
importantes quel défi technologique
ont-ils dû relever pour supporter une
circulation de plus en plus
[Musique]
dense et traverser la scène avec des
portées allant jusqu'à 200 m
d'envergure nous allons vous raconter
400 ans d'innovation
technologique et vous révéle
l'incroyable patrimoine des ponts de
Paris avec leur architecture tantôt
moyenageuse tantôt
exubérante tantôt moderne les ponts de
Paris font partie des monuments de la
capitale les plus appréciés des
visiteurs étrangers mi bout àabout il
représente tous ensemble près de 6 km de
traversée au-dessus de la scène chaque
jour ils permettent le déplacement de
plus de 4 millions de véhicules et si
aujourd'hui Paris compte au total 37
ponts il y a 500
ans la capitale du royaume de France
pourtant l'une des plus grandes cités de
l'Occident ne compte pas plus de cinq
ponts pour traverser la
scène il y a sur la rive gauche le petit
pont et le pont
Saint-Michel et sur la rive droite
le pont Notre-Dame le pon au change et
le pon au Meier qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui 5 ponts pas un de plus et ce
qui peut surprendre c'est leur aspect
tous ces ponts sont lottis c'est-à-dire
pourvue d'habitation à l'époque à Paris
les ponts sont habités on le voit sur
des lithographies d'époque c'est très
beau c'est très très beau les maisons
des deux côtés du pont ce sont vraiment
des maisons à plusieurs étages 2 3 4
étages
alors on met des maisons d'abord parce
que dans les villes médiévales la place
est chère et donc que dans chaque projet
de ce type il y a également un projet de
de
lotissement alors c'est assez étonnant
de s'imaginer effectivement la traversée
d'un pont à l'époque le pont au Change
par exemple le pont Notre-Dame également
on traversait une rue finalement on
avait de part et d'autres une rangée de
maison et finalement la vue sur la scène
n'était pas du tout possible offrant le
passage d'une rive à l'autre ces ponts
sont des lieux
stratégiques des axes de circulation
incontournable dans la
capitale leur fréquentation et leur
popularité en font des lieux privilégié
pour le commerce alors le pon au change
notamment va être dédié plutôt à des
activités bancaires comme comme son nom
l'indique le pont Notre-Dame est dédié à
des enseignes de marchand merciers donc
sont comme des anti on pourrait dire de
nos jours souvent il y a une boutique en
bas des artisans des des gens qui
réparent les vêtements les chaussures et
cetera et cetera c'est des ou des
bijoutiers d'ailleurs aussi souvent ils
vivent au rez-de-chaussée ils ont la
boutique et ils vivent au-dessus c'est
très pratique pour pour tout le
monde si ces ponts sont peu
nombreux c'est parce que leur
construction est chaque fois un nouveau
Paris il faut leur créer des fondations
dans le lit de la scène avec les moyens
de
l'époque
pour relever le
défi les bâtisseurs n'ont alors pas
d'autre solution que de planter des
centaines de pieux de bois dans le fond
du fleuve un pont de bois s'appuie en
général sur des fils de pieux on appelle
ces pieux des aiguille donc ce sont des
arbres des poteau de section carré qu'on
enfonce à partir d'une embarcation à
l'aide une grosse masse et le choc va
permettre au pieux de s'enfoncer
progressivement
en fait la plupart des ponts sont bâtis
sur piloti qu'on a enfoncé avec des
systèmes de de de de marteau très
puissant et ensuite on va construire un
plancher pour relier les différentes
files de pieux on a une portée qui est
limitée en général à 6 m 6 m c'est la
portée ordinaire d'une d'une poutre de
bois mais ces ponts de bois sont
extrêmement
fragiles car la Seine est loin d'être un
long fleuve tranquille ces berges ne
sont pas encore domestiquées et les cru
hivernales peuvent être d'une violence
dévastatrice quasiment tous les 20 30 40
ans il y a une crue importante qui
emporte un voire tous les ponts de Paris
presque simultanément qu'il faut à ce
moment-là reconstruire dans une forme
d'urgence la saison la plus redoutable
pour les ponts de bois c'est celle de la
fonte des
glaces au printemps la glace se rond et
d'énormes blocs de glace sont chariés
sur le fleuve et viennent se fracasser
contre les piles des ponts et c'est à ce
moment-là que se produisent les
catastrophes il y a un exemple quand
même c'est le pont mari les deux arches
qui sont cô du côté de l'île Saint-Louis
s'effondre embarqué par des glaces il y
avait des maisons dessus il y a
plusieurs morts je crois une
cinquantaine de
morts et donc ces ponts sont embarqués
effectivement fréquemment au printemps
par par des glace
il faut voir queà l'époque il y avait
beaucoup de ponts qui s'écroulaient qui
s'écroulaient PAF comme ça la
destruction des ponts est une chose
extrêmement extrêmement courante et
angoissante et donc c'est un cercle
vicieux on est contraint de de devoir
réparer tout le temps ce qu'on ce qu'on
vient de
faire les colères de la scène ne sont
pas la seule
menace les incendies également se
régalent de ces structures entièrement
en bois et font régulièrement des
parmi les ponts
parisiens les incendies il se déclarent
pas spontanément naturellement mais il
se déclare notamment dans les dans les
foyers dans les fours qui se trouvent
dans ces dans ces maisons or ces maisons
jusqu'à la Renaissance elles sont en
matériaux plutôt légers hein et si une
maison commence à prendre feu comme les
maisons sont mitoyenne et bien le feu
peut se propager très rapidement pour
faire entrer Paris dans l'air moderne il
faut absolument faire appel à de
nouvelles techniques de construction la
solution sera un pont d'un nouveau
[Musique]
genre le Pont
Neuf malgré son nom c'est le plus vieux
Despont de Paris car c'est le premier à
avoir été construit en pierre au 16e
siècle alors que tous les ponts de bois
ont disparu lui a traversé les âges pour
devenir le pont favori des Parisiens et
des
touristes honnêtement quand on est sur
le bout de l'île de la Place Dauphine et
à la statue d'Henry on a une vue sur
Paris qui est sublime parce qu'on c'est
ouvert vers l'ouest on voit le Louvre on
voit l'hôtel des monnais tout ça est
absolument magnifique et franchement
l'endroit est
magique classé au patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO depuis
1991 c'est le P de tous les
records 238 m de long
20 m de
large si l'on exclut les ponts du
périphérique parisien il est encore
aujourd'hui le pont le plus long de la
capitale mais ce que l'on sait moins
c'est que pour résister au temps ce
mastodomte de Pierre a fait l'objet d'un
incroyable chantier de plus de 30
ans tout commence en
1577 hen roi de France décide de la
construction d'un nouveau pont à Paris
l'objectif est de désengorger les rues
de la capitale car en seulement de
siècles la superficie de Paris a doublé
et le nombre de Parisiens a été
multiplié par 3 pour dépasser désormais
les 300000 habitants l'une des
motivations d'Henri i c'est de de créer
une nouvelle desserte entre la rive
droite et la rive gauche à un endroit où
ces de rives ont connu un un
accroissement de de population notamment
donc dans la partie dans la partie ouest
de Paris le projet est ambitieux il
s'agit de relier en particulier le
palais du Louvre résidence du roi sur la
rive droite et le nouveau quartier en
développement de Saint-Germain des prê
sur la rive
gauche pour la première fois le pont
doit franchir la scène d'un seul jet
mais comment réussir un tel exploit avec
les moyens de construction de
l'époque les bâtisseurs du Pont Neuf
vont se montrer très habiles en tirant
parti de la géographie des
lieux à la pointe de l'île de la Cité
ils vont rblayer plusieurs îos pour
former une longue pointe de terre de
3000 m Carr qui sera un appui solide
pour la
structure et à cet endroit ils imaginent
non pas un mais deux ponts enchaînés le
premier pont mesurera 154 m entre le
quai de la Mégisserie et l'actuel quai
de l'Horloge le second sera long de 78 m
entre le quai des orphèvres et celui des
Grands Augustins la nouveauté c'est
qu'il y a une unité d'un bout à l'autre
de ce pont et qu'on joue finalement de
la pointe de l'Î de la cité pour créer
un axe une symétrie sur ce nouveau
pont aligné l'un avec
l'autre et
par une chaussée et des parms
identiques les deux ponts sembleront ne
former qu'un seul et unique grand pont
de 238 m le plus grand jamais construit
à
Paris donc finalement c'est deux ponts
pour n'en faire qu'un ça aussi c'est
original mais pour que ce pont résiste
au cru hivernal comme aux incendies pas
question cette fois-ci d'utiliser le
bois Henri I veut un pont solide alors
pour pour la première
fois on va construire un pont
entièrement en pierre l'idée c'est
d'aérer un peu la circulation à Paris de
créer un pont spectaculaire de créer un
pont qui ne ressemble absolument pas aux
autres un pont en pierre c'est vraiment
une ville qui se qui grossit qui grossit
donc il fallait prendre ce genre de
décision et pour soutenir ce pont aux
dimensions sans précédent il va falloir
construire des fondations
titanesques
alors les bâtisseurs de l'époque vont
déployer une méthode jamais utilisée à
cette ampleur la technique des
batardau un batardau est une structure
de bois qui est construite au préalable
de la fondation d'une pile de Pierre
l'objectif est d'assécher une portion du
lit de la rivière pour pouvoir
travailler à pied sec c'est un caisson
avec en général une paroie extérieure
une paroie intérieure en bois en planche
et entre ces deux parois un système de
remplissage de de terre on remplit
l'intervalle entre les parois en plus le
fait de remplir va stabiliser le caisson
le caisson peut faire 5 à 10 m de large
une fois que le caisson est implanté il
dépasse en général de d'un ou 2 m du du
niveau de l'eau deè étape vider ce bâard
d'eau de l'eau qu'il contient on peut le
vider à l'aide de saut et là cela
nécessite un personnel très important
qui travaille sans arrêt jour et nuit on
ne parvient jamais à à réaliser un bâard
d'eau complètement étanche on a toujours
des infiltrations et puis il peut
toujours survenir une crue inattendu on
peut aussi avoir un orage qui va remplir
toute la partie du fleuve qu'on aura
vidé donc c'est vraiment une course
contre la
[Musique]
montre trème étape on commence par
creuser pour essayer de trouver la roche
pour y fonder les assises de pierre du
pont 4e étape on passe dans les travaux
de maçonnerie pour bâtir cette pile
jusqu'à ce qu'elle émerge au-dessus du
batardau et ensuite 5e étape on peut
démolir le batardteau pour restaurer la
navigation chaque pile exige un travail
long et fatiguant qui impose de longs
mois d'effort quand les 10 piles
émergent enfin du fleuve vient le moment
de bâtir le pont
lui-même une question se pose alors
quelle pierre utiliser les architectes
d'Henri i ont besoin d'une pierre de
taille à la fois facile à travailler et
résistante autant et à l'humidité ils
vont choisir la pierre calcaire car elle
est disponible en grande quantité à une
distance raisonnable du chantier
parisien le pont comme tout Paris est
bâti en pierrecalquare qui vient en
partie des sous-sols de Paris des car
qui se trouve encore derrière sous Paris
enfin dont on peut voir les traces ou
des environs de Paris qui pas forcément
très très loin c'est un matériau
abondant la pierre on construit pas les
ponts en granit on les construit plutôt
dans la région parisienne en calcaire
parce que le calcaire est peut-être le
matériaux de de prédilection de de la
région parisienne le calcaire idéal se
trouve à 70 km au nord de Paris dans les
carrières de Saint-Maximin dans l'Oise
ces carrières les Romains les
utilisaient déjà à l'époque
antique fournissent une pierre blanche
de grande qualité qui deviendra la
marque des principaux monuments de Paris
autre avantage les lourds blocs de
pierre de Saint-Maximin peuvent être
facilement transportés jusqu'à Paris par
bateau l'Oise et le principal affluent
de la Sene et le périple d'environ une
centaine de kilomètres ne prend que
quelques
jours les travaux sont lents et pénibles
le chantier dure déjà depuis plus de 10
ans et le retard s'est
accumulé et ce qui va définitivement
rallonger le délai c'est la situation
politique le 2 août 1589 à saint-clou
Henri I est
assassiné les guerres de religion
déchirent Paris le chantier du pont neu
est totalement
paralysé le pont demeure inachevé seul
quelques voûes émergent au-dessus de la
scène une pause imprévue qui va durer 10
ans jusqu'à ce qu'un nouveau roi de
France Henri
demande que le chantier
reprenne les ouvriers vont pouvoir
terminer l'édification des voûtes dont
certaines font près de 20 m de large une
proesse réalisée quelques mètres
au-dessus du fleuve en utilisant la
technique du cintre de complexe forme de
bois charpenté qui permettent de
soutenir la voûte pendant sa
construction on pose le cintre qui est
une structure en bois
assemblée sur le cintre il y a des
couchis de planches he très réguliers
qui donne la forme de ce qu'on appelle
l'intrados de l'arc la partie interne de
la de la voûte et c'est sur ces couchis
qu'on va monter progressivement de
l'extérieur vers l'intérieur des assises
de pierre qu'on maçonne progressivement
jusqu'à la fameuse clé qui va bloquer la
structure une fois que tout ce système
sera en place on va pouvoir penser à
enlever le cintre il faut attendre
quelques semaines les 12 voûtes sont
ainsi bâties une à
une achever le pont va demander 8 années
supplémentaires
[Musique]
lors de son inauguration en
1607 30 ans tout juste après le début
des
travaux le pont 9 est le premier pont de
Paris à traverser le fleuve d'une seule
lancée l'accueil des Parisiens ben il va
être excellent et des touristes aussi
parce qu'on a ce pont qui est très beau
qui est majestueux c'est important de
voir la
vraiment il sort de l'ordinaire ce pont
avec ses dimensions h norme le pont ne
établit une série de records pour son
époque dans toutes les capitales
européennes il est également pourvu
d'une particularité alors unique à Paris
une légère surélévation qui distingue la
chaussée des piétons de celle des
véhicules on fait des trottoirs qui sont
une invention nouvelle il y avait jamais
eu de trottoir dans les rues moyenge n
part voilà donc c'est un P quand même
très moderne
sa décoration frappe les esprits il est
orné de tourell face son château
médiéval qui lui donne un aspect unique
à
Paris et sur ces deux flancs 381
mascarons représentent des têtes de
divinité forestière ou champêtre de la
mythologie ce sont ces têtes de
grotesques ces mascarons ils ont tous
des formes différentes avec des yeux des
nez des bouches diores
[Musique]
c'est la première fois qu'on met un tel
soin dans la construction d'un
pont avec le Pont Neuf c'est tout le
centre historique de Paris qui gagne en
prestige et en
magnificence l'esplanade qui relie les
deux parties du pont reçoit la première
statue équestre à l'effigie d'un roi que
la ville est jamais accueilli une statue
de bronze qui rend hommage au
constructeur du Pont Neuf Henri
représenté en armure et couronné de
laurier en faisant ça le roi de France
renoue avec une vieille tradition
impériale antique hein d'abord celle des
empereurs de Rome qui étit qui avait
l'autorité sur la construction des ponts
et qui se privait pas de le faire savoir
en installant des des insignes du
pouvoir sur sur ces
édifices juste en face de la statue les
constructeurs aménagent un tout nouvel
ensemble harmonieux la Place Dauphine
une place triangulaire arborée qui
accueille des logements très prisés par
la haute société de l'époque on peut
considérer que effectivement avec le
Pont Neuf et l'installation de la statue
écastre d'Henry i à la pointe de l'île
de la Cité la Place Dauphine également
le Pont Neuf constitue un plan
d'urbanisme général qui est une des
premières place Royale et comme par
décision royale le Pont Neuf est le
premier pont construit sans maison il
offre un panorama unique c'est un des
meilleurs points de vue sur Paris
puisque ça englobe finalement tous les
monuments du Louvre la scène l'Institut
de France par la suite au 17e siècle
c'est le premier qui ménage une vue une
perspective qui permet un panorama
finalement à 180 der sur la
ville apportant une nette amélioration à
la circulation entre les deux rives le
Pont Neuf permet à la Cité d'étendre de
nouveaux
faubourgs et quelques années après
on va lu découvrir une autre utilité
celle de fournir à la capitale et au
parisiens une ressource essentielle et
même
vitale
l'eau si au 17e siècle Paris est la
capitale européenne la plus étendue les
habitations parisiennes ont un défaut
qui nous semblerait aujourd'hui
difficile à accepter elles n'ont pas
l'eau
courante l'eau est distribuée par des
fontaines publiques en différents points
de la ville certaines ont un débit très
faible donc on a aussi des porteurs
d'eau qui viennent directement dans la
Seine pour s'approvisionner et
distribuer l'eau aux Parisiens c'est un
produit qu'on achète au
quotidien mais dans une ville en
perpétuelle expansion le besoin en eau
est de plus en plus grand et la
ressource vient à manquer les sources
qui alimentent Paris en eau potable sont
juste suffisantes pour la alimentation
humaine or on a besoin de beaucoup d'eau
pour un tas d'autres usages dans dans
une capitale comme Paris pour le
nettoyage pour certains usages
industriels artisanaux on boit des eau
de puits qui sont creusé dans Paris à
côté des fausses desisances qui sont
juste à côté donc tout ça est
extrêmement pollué les gens ont diverses
maladies qui sont oui qui sont même
graves et c'est grâce au Pont Neuf que
l'on va trouver la
solution une personne qui s'appelait
jeanlintelard qui était un Flamand vient
voir HRI et lui dit j'ai un système pour
faire une élévation de l'eau à partir du
des fleuves pour desservir des fontaines
et donc si vous me donnez une arche sur
le pont Neuf moi je fais une machine
élévatoire des eaux et je desserre le
quartier du Louvre et le Louvre vous
aurez de l'eau courante alors bien sûr h
est d'accord en 1602 Henry autorise la
construction de cette incroyable machine
sur le pont 9 l'idée consiste à pomper
l'eau du fleuve et pour cela les
constructeurs vont utiliser l'énergie de
la scène
elle-même on a imaginé donc une une
structure de pompage quasi industrielle
et on a utilisé la force pour ça la plus
puissante et la plus
disponible à l'endroit même où on avait
besoin de de pomper cette eau c'est la
force du fleuve
lui-même l'ingénieur fait construire une
structure sur piloti accollé au Pont
Neuf au niveau de la deuxième arche côté
rive
droite il n'a pas choisi cet emplacement
au hasard mais parce qu'ici le débit du
fleuve est à son maximum la raison en
est simple en s'engouffrant sous la
voûte étroite du pont le fleuve se
gonfle ce qui lui donne plus de
puissance l'intérêt des ponts dans
l'écoulement de l'au c'est que il crée à
plusieurs endroits un resserrement du
fleuve qui a été utilisé pour installer
des moulins ça cré un accroissement de
courant qui est très utile comme force
motrice sous le bâtiment l'ingénieur
installe une énorme roue en bois de
plusieurs mètres de large qui plonge
dans la
Sene il y avait une très grande roue
assez large qui était immergé dans le
dans le lit de la rivière c'est elle
qui qui transmettait la force du fleuve
par un système d'engrenage à un système
de
piston
qui permettait de faire monter l'eau
dans un réservoir qui était situé une
dizaine de mètres au sommet du bâtiment
formant la pompe la roue tourne au
rythme moyen de TR tours complets par
minute l'eau remonte dans la citerne à
la vitesse de 5 cm par seconde et
ensuite de ce réservoir par des
canalisations l'eau été distribuée dans
plusieurs endroits de Paris la pompe
fournit jusqu'à 700000 l d'eau par jour
et elle alimente le palais du Louvre et
le jardin des tueries mais aussi de
nombreuses fontaines publiques qui vont
transformer la vie de milliers de
Parisiens donc c'est l'eau de la Scine
qui est remonté grâce à cette pompe de
la
Samaritaine dans tout le quartier du
Louvre qui va approvisionner tout le
quartier Royal finalement c'est
absolument exceptionnel
l'avoir en flux constant dans dans le
Louvre quelque chose d'extraordinaire
ou et sa construction achevée cette
machine élévatrice d'eau la première
installée dans la capitale devient une
attraction et un lieu de
[Musique]
rendez-vous les Parisiens la baptis
pompe de la Samaritaine d'après la
fresque qui enorne la façade et qui
représente un fameux épisode biblique la
rencontre de Jésus et d'une porteuse
d'eau de samintarie la
[Musique]
Samaritaine
si la pompe du Pont Neuf a disparu au
19e siècle son nom est resté il est
devenu plus tard celui d'un des plus
célèbre magasin parisien La Samaritaine
aujourd'hui converti en hôtel de luxe
rapidement la pompe et le Pont Neuf
deviennent des endroits à la mode qui
attirent les flanneurs et les
commerçants on voit la scène on voit les
bateaux c'est super beau ça va être un
lieu de spectacle pendant des années ça
va être un lieu de fête ça va être un
lieu de réunion ça va être un lieu de
commerce là on va vendre les premières
clémentines les premières oranges il y a
aussi des bonimenteur partout on
installe des petites scèes on fait des
scinettes pour vendre des onans pour
vendre des médicaments miracles contre
les piqur de serpent contre les maladies
à l'époque de tout et de rien toute une
série d'échops qui vont progressivement
parasiter si on peut dire le pont des
dentistes notamment des chirurgiens
barbiers des vendeurs à la sauvette
enfin toute une série
d'activités les grandes fêtes
parisiennes se déroulent désormais sur
et autour du Pont Neuf devenue la plus
grande place de la ville et la plus
populaire grâce aux techniques
développées pour le Pont
Neuf les anciens ponts de bois vont
pouvoir être reconstruits en dur ils se
débarrassent des anciens pilotis et
renaissent dans la pierre et inant
progressivement les habitations qui les
encombraient dans les années qui suivent
au pont déjà existant s'en ajoute de
nouveau le pont au Double et autour de
l'île Saint-Louis le pont de la
Tournelle le pont Saint-Louis et le pont
Marie au 17e siècle le pont Royal est
financé par Louis X pour accompagner
l'agrandissement du palais du Louvre en
bâtissant des
les ro de France consolident le
pouvoir le pont est lieu un peu
stratégique est souvent fortifié protégé
par des tours moyenge
souvent page une douan en quelque sorte
payer pour traverser faut payer pour
traverser les marchandises donc c'est un
point un peu nralique et le contrôle du
pont est évidemment un
instrument
contrôleéconomie des P de Pierre
suffisam sol pourers siècle mais qui
vont finir par trouver leurs
limites à la fin du 18e siècle la
capitale est équipée d'une dizaine de
ponts et cela commence à être
insuffisant face à la forte croissance
démographique et économique que connaît
la
ville Paris connaît un développement
formidable la population est passée de
500000 habitants à 700000 habitants en
une dizaine d'années ou une vingtaine
d'années la situation économique est
forte en pleine santé Louis Philippe
entouré de très bons ministres développe
le pays les chemins de fer vont arriver
donc il convenait de relier la rive
droite à la rive
gauche et il y a un endroit au cœur de
Paris qui manque cruellement d'un pont
pour traverser la scène c'est cette
portion du fleuve qui s'étend entre le
Pont Royal à l'extrémité ouest du palais
du Louvre et le pont neu soit près d'un
km de qu sans aucune possibilité de
passer sur l'autre rive il y a pas
beaucoup de pont dans cette parti de
Paris les ponts ils sont beaucoup plus
loin en 1801 dans cet intervalle
Napoléon 1er a fait construire le pont
des ARS mais cet élégant ouvrage fait de
maçonnerie et de poutrell de fonte n'est
qu'une légère passerelle pour piéton
impraticable pour les chevaux et les
calèches l'absence de pont sur cette
distance en plein centre historique
oblige les véhicules à un long détour
pour passer sur l'autre rive si on fait
un pont là en face du guichet du Louvre
il y aura 260 m d'un côté et 600 et
quelques de l'autre donc c'est très
intelligent une ordonnance royale
d'avril 1831 lance le projet d'un nouvel
ouvrage d'art le pont du carousel mais
le Paris est difficile d'abord le pont
devra enjamber la scène sur près de 170
m c'est une distance record à traverser
en comparaison le pont Royal ne mesure
que 110 m et même le plus grand des deux
ponts du Pont Neuf ne fait que 154
m de plus pour parcourir pareille
distance ces ponts en pierre reposent
sur de nombreuses piles des piles qui
sont désormais considéré comme une gêne
indésirable pendant des années et des
années et des siècles même on a
construit des ponts en pierre bon avec
des grosses piles qui avait un un gros
désavantage c'est que ça ne laissait pas
toujours passer facilement les bateaux
parce que un pont c'est fait pour
circuler au-dessus et en
dessous avec l'accroissement du trafic
sur le fleuve d'une part et puis le
développement de la Marine à vapeur et
les plus gros tonnages des bateaux ça va
s'avérer un vrai conflit au 19e siècle
le pont du carousel devra donc traverser
170 m avec au max maimum de piles dans
le
fleuve pour relever ce défi deux projets
audacieux vont
s'affronter le premier projet prend la
forme d'un pont suspendu un type de pont
alors très à la
mode à l'époque plusieurs ponts
suspendus sont construits à Paris comme
le pont
d'Arcole ou le pont
Louis-Philippe une nouveauté venue
d'outreatlantique le pont suspendu est
inventé au départ aux États-Unis parce
que les États-Unis sont confrontés à des
problèmes de franchissement de rivières
parfois très importantes et avec des
moyens financiers qui sont somme toutes
limité RpoN suspendu c'est extrêmement
simple comme montage c'est une pile à
gauche une pile à droite vous mettez un
un espèce de platelage et vous suspendez
le tout avec des grands montants et des
câbles les ponts suspendus ça n'est pas
cher du tout et on peut le mettre sur
des grandes
traversées
deux piles suffisent à soutenir le pont
car son poids exerce une traction
horizontale sur les massifs d'ancrage
qui le retiennent c'est son avantage sur
un pont classique en maçonnerie qui lui
exerce tout son poids à la verticale et
a donc besoin de nombreuses piles pour
tenir
debout vous avez des través qui
atteignent 70 et même 80 m de longueur
et ça je c'est un avantage
extraordinaire du coup les pont suspendu
c'est une des techniques les plus
économiques mais les ponts suspendus ont
leur limites certains accidents jettent
même un doute sur leur
solidité ce qui va marquer un frein à la
construction de ces pond suspendus c'est
la catastrophe du pont de la basse
chaîne à anger sur lequel une troupe
était passée au pas et donc ce qui a
entraîné sa sa chute on n'est jamais
totalement sûr que ces câbles ne cachent
pas quelque part une pointe de rouille
qu'on ne pourrait pas forcément déceler
tout de suite
face à l'insécurité relative des ponts
suspendus un homme va proposer un autre
projet un projet beaucoup plus
[Musique]
ambitieux Antoine Rémy paulonceo est
polytechnicien et ingénieur des Ponts
etchaussée il imagine un pont en métal
qui avec seulement deux piles sera selon
lui plus fiable qu'un pont suspendu et
surtout beaucoup moins
cher c'est un pont de 151 m de long 12 m
de large et un pont suspendu n'aurait
pas permis 12 m de large trois arches
deux piles au milieu donc c'est un très
beau pont et très élégant l'élégance du
pont et l'esthétique ont été des
facteurs
majeurs à cette époque les derniers
ponts construits sont encore souvent en
pierre comme le pont de la
Concorde le pont des
Invalides ou le pont dienna face à la
Tour eel polonso surprend en proposant
d'utiliser la fonte un alliage de fer et
de carbone pas toujours facile à
employer sur d'aussi grandes structures
l'un des problèmes de la fonte c'est que
elle est elle résiste mal aux vibrations
et elle se casse effectivement faire un
pont en
fonte c'est très risqué c'est un Paris
audasseux parce que il y avait déjà eu
deux ponts en fonte à Paris le pont des
AR et le pont de sterlis 1801 1806 qui
ont duré chacun 4 ou 5 ans mais
l'ingénieur affirme lui qu'il a trouvé
un moyen technique de créer un pont en
fonte quasi
indestructible son pont est constitué de
deux piles en rivière sur lesquelles
s'appuie 5 volets de tub de fondte
parallèle qui constittuent TR arches de
50 m de
large l'astuce de Polonceau pour alléger
la superstructure réside dans ces tubes
de fonte c'est un des grands défis de
polonau c'est que ces tubes ils sont
vides les tubes sont vides cela permet
de diviser le poids du P par trois c'est
dire que vous avez un tube qui est coupé
en deux hein entre deux vous mettez des
lames de bois beaucoup plus
légères et vous boulonnez le tout
ensemble enfin l'ingénieur fait remplir
les tubes de bitume pour solidifier le
tout le bois est enfermé dans une
coquille de fonte avec du bitume pour
faire étanchéité pas d'humidité pas
d'air pas de vide c'est l'alliance en
fait du bois et de ces tubes de fonte
qui va faire que ces arcs tout
simplement euh vont être d'une très
grande solidité au-dessus des tubes
l'ingénieur pose une série de an
circulaire également en fonte qui font
le lien avec le tablier du pont ces an
de fonte ont cette forme particulière
pour jouer le rôle de ressort géant il a
mis des ronds que les gens ont appelé
les ronds de serviettees ces rondes
serviettes sont en fonte mais ils ne
sont amarrés ni vraiment au tablier ni
vraiment à l'arche il y a une certaine
souplesse dans le dispositif la théorie
de paonceau c'est qu'un cercle un cercle
c'est un amortisseur c'est une bonne
surface c'est une bonne
géométrie la technologie révolutionnaire
inventée par Antoine Rémy palono permet
la construction d'un pont unique en son
genre d'une longueur de 170 m il bat un
nouveau record pour l'époque il est
construit 14 mois pour un coup très
inférieur à celui des ponts de pierre le
pont du carousel ressort dans les 800000
Francs mais les autres ponts qui
entouraient le pont d'osterl le pont
d'Enna en 1806 ressortent à plus de 2
million 2 parfois donc c'est un pont
pour reprendre un mot de poonau qui
n'est pas
dispendieux le 30 octobre
1834 le roi LouisPhilippe inaugure le
pont du carousel avec leurs 47 m
d'ouverture les trois arches sont les
plus larges jamais réalisés une prouesse
technique l'accueil des Parisiens ils
disent que c'est miraculeux c'est
miraculeux l'esthétique du pont les
délai de réalisation ils étaient
enthousiastes
enthousiastes ça a été considéré comme
une réussite technique et architecturale
absolument remarquable le pont du
carousel rend le trafic plus fluide dans
le centre de Paris c'est un pont qui va
très bien durer enfin il durera quand
même presque un
siècle s'il a finalement dû être
remplacé par un pont de béton armé en
1930 c'est parce qu'au 19e siècle une
révolution technologique a forcé les
ponts à se
métamorphoser cette révolution ce sont
les nouveaux moyens de locomotion qui
dès les années 1800 50 envahissent les
rues parisiennes à l'époque on compte
rapidement près de 9000 chevaux attelés
sur l'avenue des
ChampsÉlysées lourd large et de plus en
plus nombreux il provoque une hausse
sans précédent du trafic parisien les
anciens ponts sont élargis et beaucoup
de nouveaux ponts deviennent
nécessaires Paris se voit doter de
nouveaux ponts sous son grand empire une
quinzaine de ponts construit par
c'est beaucoup et surtout dans le centre
de PAP ces ponts ne sont plus seulement
des infrastructures ils sont des
monument à part entière sur lequel le
pouvoir pose sa marque et qui glorifie
le savoir-faire technologique
français et dans cette nouvelle
génération de pont il y en a un qui va
donner à Paris un rayonnement
international en surpassant tous les
records
établis
ce jour d'octobre
1896 au centre de la capitale a lieu une
cérémonie
solennelle le président de la République
Félix fort et Nicolas i le tzar de
Russie poste ensemble la première pierre
d'un pont qui va marquer l'histoire de
Paris le pont Alexandre
i ce point Alexandre i doit son nom à
l'alliance Franco qui s'est scellé
auparavant on fait vraiment un acte
d'urbanisme majeur avec le pont
Alexandre i les concepteurs du pont ont
reçu la mission d'imaginer un pont
fastueux c'est pourquoi ils l'ont doté
d'une très riche
ornementation au total plus de 50 œuvres
d'art le décor il est sublime il est
magnifique il est très large il est
majestueux mais cette esthétique cache
une méga structure
spectaculaire 150 m de long
30 m de large pour un pont en acier qui
va exiger des proèes techniques en avant
sur leur
temps dès le départ le cahier des
charges du futur pont Alexandre i
additionne les difficultés la première
c'est qu'il s'inscrit dans une
transformation radicale de tout le
quartier à l'au d'un événement d'empleur
internationale l'Exposition Universelle
de 1900 exposition hors norme qui
célèbre l'entrée du monde dans le 20e
siècle elle s'étendra sur 120 hectares
au cœur de Paris et attend 50 millions
de visiteurs ce sera la plus importante
des expositions universelles jamais
organisé c'est une exposition très
fastueuse c'est vraiment la ville de
Paris qui est mise à l'honneur la ville
des lumières
notamment décidé à impressionner le
monde entier en faisant plus fort encore
que l'exposition de 1889 qui a vu naître
la tour la capitale française s'est
lancé dans des travaux pharaoniques pour
permettre la construction d'une entrée
monumentale deux nouveaux bâtiments sont
élevés le Grand Palais et le petit
palais dans le plus pur style hardco en
vogue à l'époque on construit le grand
et le petit palais et on a cette
magnifique perspective quand même une
des plus belles perspectives de Paris
entre les invalides et les
champsélysé
cette nouvelle perspective court sur
près d'un km 200 depuis l'actuelle place
Georg clémenau entre les deux palais et
sur l'autre rive jusqu'au dô doré de
l'Hôtel des Invalides pour faire le lien
un nouveau pont est donc indispensable
et pour être à la hauteur de l'événement
il va devoir relever un certain nombre
de
défis d'abord dans un souci esthétique
le pont devrait être à l'échelle de la
nouvelle avenue et donc adopter une
largeur de 40 m ce qui en fera le pont
le plus large de
Paris deuxè défi pour gêner le moins
possible la circulation fluviale les
ingénieurs se voient imposer un pont
sans aucune pile dans le fleuve le site
est particulièrement contraignant d'une
part parce que les rives sont assez
basses et également parce qu'à cet
endroit la scène fait un coude qui est
une contrainte pour la navigation on ne
peut pas construire de de pile en
rivière surtout qu'il y a des ponts de
part et
d'autre trè défi pour ne pas gêner la
nouvelle perspective la courbure du pont
doit être aussi basse que
possible fait un pont très surbaissé il
fait que 1 m d'élévation ce qui est très
très peu on veut un pont qui soit le
plus bas possible pour que la vue du
piéton puisse traverser la scène voir
l'esplanade des invalidesun côté voir de
l'autre côté bien sû le grand et le
petit palais le problème c'est que plus
un pont est aplati plus charge de son
poids se répercute sur les rives plus on
fait plat plus on fait des poussées
latérales et plus c'est surbisser plus
ça crée de poussé forte donc on fait des
culés en béton de chaque côté mais qui
sont absolument colossales pour
supporter ce poids et cette poussée
latérale de dans les
culet pour résumer le futur ouvrage doit
rallier les deux rives sur 107 m de long
sans aucune pile en rivière en étant
assez haut pour laisser pass les bateaux
mais assez bas pour ne pas gêner la
vue et pour finir l'ouvrage doit être
parfaitement symétrique et décoratif
pour être à la hauteur des célébrations
d'amitié francousse il s'agit d'un
modèle de P monumental qui à la fois on
met plein la vue et qui est de fait une
presse technique cette presse technique
en fait on la mesure pas forcément à
l'époque ce chantier est sans doute le
plus ambitieux imaginé pour un pont
parisien et les concepteurs du Pont
Alexandre i vont devoir pousser à
l'extrême toutes les performances
techniques de leur
époque l'ingénieur chargé des travaux
s'appelle Jean reésal l'un des meilleurs
spécialistes des ponts
métalliques il a participé 4 ans plus
tôt à la construction du pont mIRABO un
pont d'acier de 170 m de long entre les
quartiers d'oteuil de passie rive droite
et ceux de javel et de Grenelle rive
gauche
ce pont s'appuie sur deux piles massives
mais Jean Résal va réussir à se passer
totalement de pil pour le pont Alexandre
II la construction commence le 28 mai
1887 l'idée de génie de Jean reésal
c'est de multiplier les points d'appui
il a imaginé 15 Arces parallèle
constitué d'un acier moulé de haute
résistance et qui passe le fleuve d'une
jambé la solution qui s'impose est de
concevoir une arche qui franchira la
scène en une seule en une seule portée
mais extrêmement basse le rapport de la
hauteur de l'arc à sa longueur est de 1
à 17 ce qui est extrêmement
contraignant et pour reprendre la
poussée de cette arche très surbaissé il
faut des fondations extrêmement
massives l'ennui c'est que sur les rives
de la Sene à cet endroit le solumide est
stable pour les fondations de son pont
Jean reésal va devoir faire appel à un
procédé rarement
utilisé le procédé trigger basé sur un
système de caisson
pressurisé la technique qui est utilisée
pour construire ces fondations est celle
des fondations par air comprimé c'est
une technique un peu différente de celle
des batardo qui est en fait beaucoup
plus pratique elle a été mise au point
au milieu du 19e siècle alors en
l'occurrence il s'agit de caisson creux
très grand puisquils font 30 par 40 m
sur 3 M50 de de
hauteur il s'agit de caissons étanches
qui sont ouverts en dessous dans
lesquels on va projeter de l'air
comprimé et ce qui permet d'enfoncer le
caisson au fur à mesure que les ouvriers
creuse et évidemment à sec la terre que
creuseent les ouvriers est évacué par le
sommet et progressivement les cissons
s'enfoncent sous le niveau du
sol l'eau qui filtre est évacué par des
pompes on met des personnes dans un
caisson qui vont creuser au sol et puis
ensuite on sort l'eau et le et la pierre
Gustave Effel a utilisé la même méthode
pour consolider deux pieds de sa tour
mais si le procédé trigger a prouvé son
efficacité il n'est pas sans risque à
l'époque on n pas très fort dans ces
procédés de compression décompression et
donc il y a des accidents euh je crois
même qu'il y a un accident mortel au
pont Alexandre
i mais à l'époque c'était la seule
méthode qu'on avait c'était d'aller sous
caisson
compressé creusé dans le
sous-sol à environ 20 m de profondeur
les caissons atteignent des zones de
calcaire solid à cette étape il se pose
et forment une base stable pour la
construction de gigantesqu fondations de
pierres sur chaque rive les appuis du
tablier forment ainsi deux épée blocs
sans doute les fondations les plus
massives jamais construites à
Paris pendant ce temps à 300 km de Paris
le pont lui-même est en construction
dans les usines cidérurgiques du creusau
en
sonnéloire les éléments constitutifs du
pont les vousoussoirs sont fondus et
moulés en
acier
les plus lourds pèent 7 tonnes ils sont
acheminés à Paris par
pénich et sur place comme il est
impossible d'utiliser un échafaudage sur
piloti qui empêcherait le passage des
bateaux il a fallu imaginer une solution
plus innovante le Alexandre 3 il est
construit donc avec des voussoirs qui
sont boulonnés les un au autres mais
pour avant les boulonner il faut les
poser sur un cintre sur un support donc
on va conu un échafaudage considérable
parce qu'il va franchir toute la seène
pour construire arche par arche une
immense passerelle provisoire est lancé
au-dessus de la
scène un assemblage de poutrell
métallique long de 130 m qui enjambble
le fleuve cette passerelle permet aux
ouvriers d'assembler les Arces d'acier
du pont chaque arc étant constitué de
trois vousousoirs on va construire
chacque arche on va déplacer
l'échafaudage surrail construire l'arche
suivant
et as de suite lorsquune arche est
complète la passerelle aérienne est
déplacée à la main sur plusieurs mètres
pour l'arche
suivante et ainsi de
suite d'avoir une arge de 30 m ou 40 m
pierre on a une marche qui fait toute la
largeur de la
scè le pont Alexandre 3 quand on regarde
de près c'est vraiment un exploit
technique andre 3 est le premier pont
préfabriqué un chantier spectaculaire
que les Parisiens ne se lassent pas de
venir admirer la construction du pont
Alexandre 3 accompagne aussi le
développement de la mécanisation sur les
chantiers on trouve par exemple des
grues à vapeur des petits vagonnets qui
servent à transporter ces pièces qui
sont assez assez
massives ce mécano géant va permettre de
poser les 15 arcs du pont dans le temps
record de 200
[Musique]
jours l'ouvrage va alors recevoir une
décoration sans
précédent aux deux extrémités quatre
imposantes colonnes de 17 m de haut
surmonté de renommé et de pégas de
bronze doré à la feuille
d'or à leur pied 4 lion mené par des
enfants semble protéger l'accès du
pont une abondance de sculpture qui
fascine encore aujourd'hui il y a quatre
figures de la France à diverses époques
la France au Moyen-Âge la France à
l'époque moderne la France de Louis XIV
de part et d'autre donc on est rive
droite et rive gauche il y a des
allégories des sciences et des arts du
côté Petit Palais Grand Palais donc ça
n'est pas innocent et les renommées les
figures de la renommée allégorie de la
paix et de la guerre côté
invalide le pont est illuminé par 32
candélabres de bronze réalisé par la
même fonderie qui a fabriqué le lustre
monumental de l'Opéra Garnier
alli l'aspect prouesse technique à
l'aspect exubérant d'un décor qui est
aussi impressionnant c'est très
spécifique et de Paris dans cette
démarche effectivement d'inscrire un
monument urbain dans une esthétique plus
générale après 2 ans et demi de travaux
l'inauguration a lieu exactement à la
date prévue le 14 avril 1900 pour
l'ouverture de l'Exposition
universelle au début du 20e siècle la
capitale est forte de plus de 30
ponts au fil des années ils sont adaptés
pour accueillir le
métro et renforc pour faire face au
règne grandissant de
l'automobilecoup sont élarg
le le de la Concorde par exemple il
sontg en rajoutant des arches latéral ça
se voit pas c'est bien fait c'est
intégré onimession comme ça mais à
l'proche du 21e siècle de nouveaux
besoins se font sentir il est désormais
question de réduire la place des
voitures au profit des cyclistes et des
piétons
la capitale a besoin d'un nouveau type
de pont des passerelles qui restituent
la ville à ses habitants de nouveaux
matériaux plus légers et plus soupes
permettent désormais toutes les audaces
architecturales mais les ingénieurs vont
également affronter des difficultés
techniques que personne n'avait
imaginé l'histoire commence au début des
années
90 au cœur de Paris l'immense chantier
du Grand Louvre sétend de la cour carrée
avec l'édification de la
pyramide jusqu'au jardin des
Tuileries le projet est d'une ambition
sans précédent il va faire du Louvre le
plus grand musée du monde et l'une des
principales attractions touristique de
la
capitale mais les concepteurs du projet
ont oublié les
ponts à l'époque à la hauteur du jardin
des Tuileries il n'y a pour traverser la
qu'une seule passerelle et son état est
préoccupantit structure enté une barre
comme ça posée au travers de la scène
très très vilaine et qui était
provisoire et qui devait durer qui
devait durer quelques années qui 30 ans
plus tard était toujours là l'ouvrage
menace de
s'effondrer les autorités décident alors
de le faire
démonter on a conscience à un moment
donné quand on entreprend aussi les
travaux sur le Louvre que
un pont de cette nature n pas digne au
fond d' situation semblable l'état lance
un concours d'architecture pour un
nouveau pont de
Solferino ce sera une passerelle pour
piéton même si à l'époque les deux rives
sont dévolu aux voitures la situation
était un peu apocalyptique parce que il
y avait les kives gauches qui étaient
encombré par le bas les Kve droite qui
est encomé par le haut mais c'était des
voies de autoroutière a priori le
problème est insoluble mais parmi les
projets proposés il y en a un qui va
rapidement faire consensus une
passerelle à la silhouette originale
dessinée par un architecte ingénieur
alors quasiment inconnu Marc Mimram
l'enjeu était considérable et en même
temps je ve dire une bêtise vous pouvez
pas faire pire que ce qu'il y avait
là un pari technique et audacieux car il
s'agit en réalité de deux passerelles en
une une première passerelle en forme de
voûte franchit d'une seule portée les
106 m que mesure le fleuve à cet endroit
sans aucun appui dans l'eau
elle relie les deux KEB une deuxième
passerelle plus droite celle-là est
posée sur la première
elle relie les deux koos en leur centre
les deux passerelles se rejoignent ce
qui permettra au piéton de passer un
différemment d'un parcours à l'autre on
a décidé de non pas simplement d'aller
de d'un KO au KO mais d'aller de Koo au
KEB de Koo au KEB et de KEB à KEB en
multipliant les appuis l'architecte fait
reposer le poids de sa structure sur
quatre points au lieu de deux une idée
ingénieuse grâce à laquelle il peut se
passer de pile pour soutenir le poids de
son pont il y av une véritable recherche
pas seulement dans la forme générale du
pont dans son architecture générale mais
dans l'expression de ces détails
constructifs là il y a vraiment une
volonté d'aller plus loin dans la dans
le dessin même des des
structures grâce aux nouvelles
possibilités de calcul par
ordinateur l'architecte remplace les
poutres métallique typique de
l'architecture du 19e siècle par des
éléments galbés qui dessinent la courbe
élancée de la structure l'idée que on a
des structures assez légères àjourées et
qui vont du coup euh rés à la
compression qui pouvoir être moulé et
moulé ça permet de d'avoir des formes
précises et adapté effectivement à à cet
aspect de boussoir qui est préférable
puis des formes plus fines plus
travaillé le projet a tout pour réussir
mais rien ne va se passer comme
prévu le chantier débute en
1997 20 convois exceptionnels acheminent
les six arcs géants de tô et d'acier
préfabriqué en usine chacun d'entre eux
pèse 150 tonnes au total la structure
fait le poids de 3 Airbus à
380 bien sûr on fait ça la nuit on pas
gêner la circulation des
bateaux pendant 6 nuit successiv ces
éléments sont soudés les uns aux autres
sur place grâce au travail de 11
soudeurs monteurs il faut pouvoir
radiographier et vérifier que la soudure
est bonne c'est pas tellement soudé
qu'il faut qu' est difficile mais c'est
vérifié que la soudure est bonne et
grâce aux technologies importé nucléaire
notamment on vérifie que la soudure bien
pris à l'intérieur du du matériau qu' a
pas de défaut de
fissure de de vide une semaine est
nécessaire pour achever le montage
complet de la structure et une nuit
d'octobre
1998 le dernier élément la clé de voûte
est
posé une très grande grue a été utilisée
pour la pose de ces éléments V de
Rotterdam c'est des GR qui servent aussi
au travaux maritimes donc sont qui
permett soulever des charges
considérables cela doit se faire très
vite parce que la grue flottante en
question coûte très cher de location
elle vient de Hollande elle elle vient
une date fixe le lendemain une semaine
après elle doit partir sur un autre
chantier et donc c'est c'est assez
magique les éléments s'enoîent au
centimè
près appudissement des Parisiens qui
sont massés sur lesqu pour l'occasion
malgré le
froid spectaculaire parce que tout d'un
coup va poser un élément qui va achever
le pont mais c'est un
moment
extraordinaire quand les trois éléments
sont
assemblés et que
je je chemine à travers la structure
pour rejoindre la partie centrale et
rejoindre l'autre
rive au milieu de la nuit
manière à peu près instable instable
mais tout ça tient sur quelques
boulons c'est génial une
émotion que je ressens aujourd'hui là en
vous en
par la nouvelle passerelle est en place
mais il y a encore des mois de travail
les ouvriers posent un platelage
métallique puis le revêtement final un
plancher en bois
d' ce bois exotique a été choisi parceil
est
et ne demande aucun entretien 12 tonnes
de bois tropical sont nécessaires pour
recouvrir les 2000 m car de la
passerelle l'équivalent de 5 terrains de
basket le 36e pont de Paris n'attend
plus que ses premiers piéton mais le
jour de l'inauguration la fête va
tourner
court le 14 décembre
1999 400 personnes don la ministre de la
Culture
vin inaugurer la nouvelle passerelle pas
mal de mondeite pas non plus noir de
mais avait du
me premier problème la passerelle
s'avère
glissante la faute au revêtement en bois
exotique mouillé par la pluie mais ce
n'est pas tout sous les pieds des
invités rapidement une sensation de
balancement apparaît d'un coup on sent
voilà le pont qui commence à bouger mais
avec une une certaine force comme si
quelqu'un était en train de de secouer
comme ça ça c'est une situation de
d'inconfort auquel on s'attendait pas
évidemment et donc voilà moment
d'incertitude et on s aperçu que le
simple fait que les gens déambule et
bien avait créé un mouvement qui petit à
petit avait amplifié une oscillation du
pont et cette oscillation elle était
devenue extrêmement
sensible gênante
une passerelle glissante et instable
évidemment l'affaire fait grand bruit de
jours après l'inauguration la préfecture
émet un arrêté d'interdiction publique
la passerelle est
inutilisable unénomène qu'on connaissait
pas on connaissa th on connaissait pas
et en fait il s'avère que on nait jamais
construit jusqu'ors des ouvrages aussi
légers qui sontune telle portée pour
Marc Mimram et son équipe il faut
rapidement trouver des solutions le
problème du plattelage en bois glissant
est résolu grâce à la pose d'un
revêtement
antidérapant coup des travaux 300000 €.
mais la question du balancement est plus
complexe à régler d'autant que le même
malâ frappe simultanément d'autres
passerelles
récentes à Londres au Royaume-Uni
quelques mois plus tard le jour même de
de son inauguration le Millennium Bridge
de l'architecte Norman Foster une
spectaculaire passerelle de 325 m se
met-elle aussi à balancer
vigoureusement c'est théoriquement un
peu complexe mais il faut juste
comprendre que quand vous
excitez une passerelle c'est comme
exciter une corde la corde d'un la corde
d'un instrument le pont il il a
certain mode particulière ave des
fréquences particulières comme une corde
de guitare vibreve une certaine note et
du coup créer une oscillation qui
s'amplifie c'est donc le pas de la foule
qui provoque dans certaines conditions
le balancement de ces grandes structures
parfois même un vent violent peut
suffire ce fut le cas pour le pont de
takacoma dans l'État de Washington aux
États-Unis en novembre
toute structure a une fréquence propre
que vous pouvez
exciter et qui pourra aller jusqu'à la
ruine de
l'ouvrage la solution est complexe à
mettre en œuvre il faut déshosser la
passerelle pour y installer un système
totalement nouveau il s'agit de ce que
l'on appelle depuis des amortisseurs
dynamiqu compensés des ressorts en acier
et des balanciers qui vont empêcher le
phénomène le ressort est calculé de
manière à à répondre à la fréquence dont
je viens de vous parler et la
masse amortit le mouvement le mouvement
d'ouvrage qui est lié à la
marche pour empêcher le mouvement de
rouli horizontale des balanciers sont
suspendus au poutre transversal du
centre de la
structure lourd de plusieurs tonnes ils
sont réglés sur une fréquence très basse
0,8 Hz et pour contrer l'effet de
torsion d'autres amortisseurs sont
boulonnés au poutrell sur les côtés eux
aussi très lourds ils sont réglés à
1,94 et 2,22
Hz si vous mettez dans votre dispositif
quelque chose qui va atténuer
l'oscillation quelque chose qui freine
un ressort par exemple comme un frein ou
un contrepoid qui va se déplacer qui va
contrarier cette oscillation on n plus
du coup dans ce schéma de d'oscillation
libre il s'agit effectivement d'atténuer
ces vibrations en installant des
systèmes d'amortisseur he c'est comme
des systèmes de pendule ou de ressort
qui vont
absorber ponctuellement les vibrations
et éviter qu'elles se transmettent à
l'ensemble de l'ouvrage au total 14
amortisseurs sont installés cachés par
les poutres de l'arc l'ensemble du
système alourdit la passerelle de 30
tonnes cout des travaux 900000 €
émentaire rouverte au public depuis
novembre 2000 la passerelle n'a plus de
problème de stabilité elle a été adoptée
par les Parisiens et par les touristes
depuis que les quais sont devenus
totalement piétons sur les deux rives la
passerelle avec ses accès multiples
remplit complètement son
rôle le pontol ferino représente
finalement un projet assez clairvoyant
sur
la situation actuelle de Paris l'idée de
mettre en relation les Koo et les kebas
était déjà une manière d'espérer
peut-être que les voix surberges
seraient débarrassé définitivement de
leur voiture ce qui était impossible
hier et s'est révélé tout à
fait naturel aujourd'hui les
mésaventures de la passerelle ont
durablement marqué l'histoire de
l'ingénierie désormais toutes les
passerelles piétonnes de longue portée
inclu dès l'origine des systèmes
d'amortisseurs c'est le cas en
particulier 6 ans plus tard en 2006 de
la passerelle Simone de Beauvoir
construite entre la Bibliothèque de
France et le quartier de Bercy une
balade de 194 m au-dessus de la
scène c'est un phénomène d'ailleurs qui
se voit dans beaucoup de passerelles
dans le monde même sont souvent traité
comme ça pas seulement les traversées
technique fonctionnel efficace original
créative mais aussi comme des lieux de
promenade cette passerelle est le 37e
pont de Paris et à ce jour le dernier
construit
elle a rejoint la prestigieuse famille
de ses ponts
monumentaux des ouvrages d'art emprint
de la majesté de la pierre
médiévale de la puissance des fondes du
19e siècle
ou de la légèreté des alliages
métalliques
contemporains
c'est grâce à eux que Paris est l'une
des grandes capitales les plus ouvertes
sur le fleuve qu'il a vu naître et
encore aujourd'hui l'une des plus
élégantes cités du
[Musique]
monde